[Music]
the only thing better than a good horror
movie is 25 of them
one after the other until you can no
longer remember a time when you weren't
screaming and didn't have crippling jump
scare anxiety
from creature features to team
screamathons and indie darlings
these movies are all available on
netflix and all guaranteed to scare your
pants off
here are the 25 best horror movies to
stream on netflix right now
the wailing the atmospheric artificial
thrills of k-horror meets the tried and
true tale of demonic possession in
2016's the whaling which follows a
police officer as he tries to uncover
the truth about a mysterious violent
sickness sweeping through his south
korean mountain village
although the wailing is the slowest of
slow burns running a ridiculous 2 hours
and 36 minutes
director hong jin na earns every second
of his movie's run time
by ramping up the tension to the perfect
pitch and pacing out the scares like a
pro
the babadook this entry from down under
was on everyone's list of the best
horror films of 2015
and it's not hard to see why tense
atmospheric visually striking
and with an oscar-worthy performance by
noah wiseman as a creepy kid to end all
creepy kids this story of a single
mother battling an evil storybook
creature called the babadook is high
quality nightmare material
as far as ceiling crawling anti-gravity
monsters go this guy is chilling
the unborn 2009 was a dry period for
good original horror affair
with the exception of the unborn which
has plenty to make it worth a watch a
family-centric
fetal twist on the usual possession
storyline top quality scares and
solid production values and the
surprisingly great cast the unborn asks
all of the important questions you think
it's possible to be haunted by someone
who's never even born
not only does oscar-nominated actor gary
oldman turn
up but senior citizen scares like this
one will probably keep you from visiting
grandma for a long
long time
sinister if you've been the soldier for
ethan hawk since his 1990s dreamboat
days ended
you'll definitely dig him in this
grown-up role as a skeptical dad who
doesn't quite believe that he's
discovered a haunted box of super eight
reels
until it's too late of course and the
scares are coming fast and furious
released in 2012 sinister does a nice
job of matching up the contemporary
concept of found footage horror
with the feel of a classic haunting
flick and the home movies that are
central to the film's plot are genuinely
creepy
from the first scene on the host before
he wowed the world of snowpiercer
director bong joon ho was a director of
the best korean creature feature of the
early arts
the 2006 film the host tells the story
of a hapless dad searching for his
daughter who has been kidnapped by an
acrobatic sewer dwelling beast with
murder on its mind
the movie is as much as godzilla's
satire as it is a straightforward
monster flick and the director's
trademark slapstick moments are great
tension relievers and a very very taught
thriller
a girl walks home alone at night as
stylish as she is deadly the veiled
vampire at the center of ana lily amir
paul's debut feature film
is the best kind of bad girl and
remarkably sympathetic for a person who
feasts on the blood of the living
the pacing in this horror flick is a bit
slow but made up for by the beauty of
its leading lady and his atmospheric
black and white world when blood spills
in a mere poor setting of bad city the
splatter is downright elegant
housebound this kiwi horror comedy takes
a tongue-in-cheek approach to a classic
trope instead of a movie about a haunted
house
it's a movie about a haunted house
arrest small time criminal kylie is
sentenced to eight months on her parents
property which happens to have an angry
ghost in residence
kylie's ankle bracelet also serves as a
clever answer to the question that
plagues most haunted horror films
unlike the dopey characters in other
movies who inexplicably stick around to
be terrorized the heroine of housebound
can't leave her ghost-ridden residence
aren't you lucky carly having all that
fancy technology on your foot choosing
between brutal ghost death and a prison
sentence was never so difficult
bad milo what is it
you got a thing in your butt thanks to
the oversaturated nature of the horror
genre bad milo is not the only movie you
can watch in which a murderous
monster emerges from someone's tushy it
is however the best of the bunch
sorry dreamcatcher starring longtime
comedy icon and state veteran ken marino
bad milo tells the story of a man who
discovers that his lifelong
gastrointestinal issues are the result
of a demonic palip which escapes from
his ass to kill his enemies at will
despite its incredible gross premise the
movie writers above basic bathroom
horror to be reliably entertaining
and milo the butt gremlin who kinda
looks like the baby from dinosaurs is
really pretty loveable
i don't like you anymore
hush the ordinary home invasion thriller
gets kicked up a notch by the injection
of a unique twist in hush
the heroine is death low on gore and
high on suspense the 2016 film succeeds
despite a limited budget and
almost no dialogue thanks to its
deliberate storytelling and creative use
of sound and silence to ramp up the
tension add in a stellar performance by
kate siegel who also co-wrote the film
and hush is more than worth investing
the short 80 minutes it takes to watch
dead snow gory ghastly and campy as hell
in other words dead snow fulfills all
reasonable expectations for a horror
film about nazis rising from a
snow-covered hillside to ruin a
perfectly good ski vacation
you won't get nuanced performances or
subtle hitchcockian tension from this
movie
you will however get all the
blood-splattered action you ever wanted
when will people realize that remote
cabins are absolutely terrible vacation
spots
dead silence if you're creeped out by
ventriloquist dummies and seriously who
isn't
then you'll thoroughly appreciate this
movie by horror virtuoso james wan
who delved into dummy fair in between
directing his better known project
saw and insidious starring true blood's
ryan quanton
dead silence occasionally veers into
cheesy territory but it's hard not to
when your characters are battling the
ghost of an evil ventriloquist
fortunately its premise is unique enough
and it delivers solid scares
we are what we are in this 2013 film the
parkers are a close-knit and reclusive
family bound by a mysterious shared
religious tradition but rather than draw
out that mystery we are what we are
reveals it early on and then draws its
horrors from the resulting family drama
there's plenty of blood and goods here
too but the american gothic flavor and
subtle character development elevated
above the average goldfest
cabin fever patient zero fans of the
original cabin fever will like this film
for the same reasons as they love the
original it's gruesomely graphically
disgusting
possibly even more than its predecessors
centering on the origin story of the
series flesh-eating virus
and the worst bachelor party in history
cabin fever patient zero
reveals the shocking truth honeymoon if
you've been missing actress rose leslie
since her untimely exit from game of
thrones this slow burn horror flick
about a honeymoon gone wrong
will put her back on your tv screen
leslie stars opposite harry treadaway in
a story about
two newlyweds whose post-nuptial bliss
at a secluded cabin
is rudely interrupted by something
strange lurking in the woods
without spoiling anything let's just say
the honeymoon gets real weird
real fast before it's officially over it
follows
with every classic horror trope having
been done and redone to death it's rare
to find a movie that looks and feels
like something you've never seen before
wherever you are it's somewhere walking
straight for you
you can do is pass it along to someone
else but with its unique premise slow
pacing
and inventive soundtrack it follows as
one of the creepiest and
most original horror releases in years a
particularly impressive feat considering
its small budget and use of old school
practical effects to bring the scares
a million dollar cgi monster has nothing
and a half
naked toothless intruder peeing on your
kitchen floor take our word for it
the awakening for spooky atmospheric
tension and a unique historic premise
look no further than the awakening set
in the aftermath of the first world war
this movie follows its heroine to a
boarding school with a ghost problem or
is it
with its characters as haunted by the
horrors of wars as they were by any
spirit on campus
the awakening is big on suspense and the
mystery of what kind of evil they're
dealing with persists almost all the way
to the end
vhs for those with short attention spans
there's nothing better than a
feature-length anthology of many horror
movies
and vhs is among the best using every
available found footage concert
from recorded skype calls to vacation
videos it tells a series of scary
stories that run the gamut from alien
abduction to wilderness monsters
20 minutes at a time if you dig the vhs
anthology a pair of sequels in the same
format
vhs2 and vhs viral are also available to
stream on netflix
trollhunter not to be confused with the
original animated netflix series troll
hunters or even the amazing
troll too
troll hunter is director andre alverdo's
first horror movie
so catch it while it's still on netflix
set in the remote forested northern
fjords of norway
this found footage mockumentary follows
a group of students as they try to catch
an elusive species of giant troll on
camera
without being eaten or trampled alive in
the process needless to say
some of the characters are more
successful than that endeavor than
others
ravenous in this 1999 film a group of
middle 19th century military
frontiersmen
saved the life of a stranger who
stumbles into their camp who then thanks
the frontiersman by having them all for
dinner
man eats the flesh of another he absorbs
the other man's strength
cannibal hillbilly stories are a dime a
dozen but ravenous breathes fresh life
into the trope of an awesome cast
a nifty historical angle and some
unexpectedly hilarious jokes about the
etiquette of eating your fellow man
tucker and dale versus evil
i was evil walking right now he looks
like he's gonna walk it off he's gonna
be fine
if you're looking to scream with
laughter rather than terror it doesn't
get better than this pitch perfect send
up of the cam slasher genre
tyler levine and alan two dick star is a
pair of backward bffs who are just
trying to enjoy a relaxing vacation at
their fixer-upper cabin in the mountains
but when a group of peppy judgmental
college kids set up a camp nearby a
series of absurd misunderstandings
unleash an unstoppable tide of rage
violence and accidental deaths by
woodchipper
an american werewolf in london the best
practical special effects you'll ever
see in a creature feature belong to this
classic werewolf movie from 1981.
an american werewolf in london is as
darkly funny as it is terrifying
in a dry british sort of way like when
the mangled spirits of the various
victims of david's lunar activities
turn up to scold him for not only
killing innocent londoners but by being
such an unrefined war about it
what shall i do suicide
they just don't make horror movies like
this anymore although they tried bless
their little hearts
don't confuse this one with the 1997
film an american werewolf in paris which
was a pile of hot garbage
odd thomas in this film based on a book
by dean
koontz anton yelchin plays a small town
fry cook
and part-time vigilante psychic who uses
his gifts to hunt down killers he runs
into trouble when his town is invaded by
an evil beyond anything he's seen before
as horror flicks go utter thomas is more
whimsical and occasionally sentimental
but yelchin is so charming in the title
role that she won't miss the jump scares
a bit
hellraiser on its surface hellraiser is
a cautionary tale about
buying and solving puzzle boxes from
sketchy moroccan treat vendors but
really it's all about master of horror
clive barker and his first foray into
the grotesque fantasy world that would
spawn close to a dozen films the acting
won't win any awards and the gore is
over the top even for a horror film but
hell raises unique combination of
demonic lore and
lingering cringe shots of slimy torn off
people parts
makes it a must watch for anyone who
claims to be serious about horror
the fly everyone loves david
cronenberg's 1986 version of sci-fi
horror story the fly but this version
from 1958 came first
it's a classic science fiction film with
a cast that includes everybody's
favorite cadaverous leading man
vincent price as far as the plot line
you know the drill
mad scientist gets over ambitious has
careless lab accident
transfigure yourself into gruesome
half-human half-fly monstrosity but back
in the mid
20th century this movie was
groundbreaking and even by modern day
standards
it goes to some shockingly dark places
the shining
we know you've seen the shining or at
least the thousands of pop culture
references to it
no tv and no beer make homer
something something go crazy
don't mind if i don't
but no matter how many times you've seen
it you haven't seen it enough
stanley kubrick's 1980 adaptation of
stephen king's terrifying haunted hotel
novel was notoriously loathed by the
author
but it's still a brilliant piece of
filmmaking from a master the shining
packs in
plenty of gut-punching terror focusing
on a horrific performance by jack
nicholson as a man coming undone in the
worst way
in kubrick's hands a slow and lingering
visual crawl down an empty hallway at
the overlook hotel is more terrifying
than any jump scare but really see it
for the hundreds of pop culture
references that will suddenly make sense
trap you sip what have we told you about
writing on the walls go to your room
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our youtube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love too